je sais une deuxième campagne électorale
à la tête du npd cette fois ci avec deux
fois plus d'argent de moyens financiers
qu'en 2019 un seul siège de plus ça fait
ça fait cher du siège mais on est
tellement fier de quintin de la campagne
qu'on a fait parce que on a eu la chance
de partager notre message on a eu la
chance de partager les défis des gens de
parler est ce une idée de comment on
peut améliorer la vie des gens grâce à
la science les gens vous avez patinage
de plus je pense que ce qu'on a fait on
a vraiment augmenté notre fondation on à
augmenter l'appui à travers le pays on a
augmenté le nombre des gens qui ont voté
pour nous et on est le seul parti
d'opposition qui a gagné plus de sièges
donc c'était une élection peu bizarre
mais malgré tout ça on est vraiment
réussir à
convaincre les gens que on est une
option mais oui à ça reste le travail
continue et on doit continuer le travail
particulièrement au québec comment vous
faites pour convaincre les gens comment
vous faites pour traduire cet appui là
en sièges en députés parce que ça ça
fonctionne pas et c'est la grande
question on va faire une analyse on a
embauché à quelques heures pour le faire
pour identifier
stratégiquement qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire on a rapproché dont on était plus
proche pour gagner plus de sièges mais
il ya quelque chose qui manque et où on
va faire une analyse parce que je crois
profondément que les gens vont être
mieux servir avec un député néo
démocrate
vous avez la campagne a beaucoup tourné
autour de vous avec une campagne centrée
autour du chef est-ce que c'était une
erreur je pense que c'est important pour
les gens les gens connaissent des chefs
du parti et j'ai eu une bonne pluie dans
les gens donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
est une force est important à mes yeux
on va aussi analyser comment on peut y
va lui et comment on peut améliorer
notre travail sur le terrain et comme
j'ai dit a pour moi je veux gagner à
travers le pays ça veut dire au québec
aussi
il ya du travail qui qui reste de
travail qu'on doit faire le gouvernement
évalue présentement les programmes des
qui ont instauré pendant la pandémie
on voit doit déterminer s'ils seront
prolongées vous avez déjà indiqué cette
semaine que vous vouliez voir une
prolongation de certains programmes
d'être pour les gens pour les petites
entreprises en taule combien temps ça
doit durer des heures je pense qu'une
chiffres une façon d'évaluer comment où
on doit arrêter c'est premièrement on
doit faire face à la pandémie et
maintenant on est dans un quatrième
vague de cette pandémie donc ça peut
nous donner une
façon d'évaluer qu'on doit arrêter au
moins on doit être sûr qu'on a vraiment
combattre cette mondial on n'est pas
dans la même dynamique les commerces
sont ouverts il ya des gens qui vont
manger au restaurant on n'est pas comme
en début de pandémie où tout était
complètement fermé l'oeil à une activité
économique il ya des gens qui disent ses
programmes d aide là ils nous empêchent
d'aller chercher les mets la main
d'oeuvre dont on a besoin on arrête tout
je dis que à ce moment en alberta et à 6
4 6 4 on a la pire situation c'était
c'est maintenant à ce moment pire que
jamais dans tulle et 18 - de cette
pandémie donc ça montre comment on est
vraiment au milieu de cette pandémie
deuxièmement qu'on en parle de l'aide
pour les petites entreprises on est
vraiment spécifique cette aide doit être
aux endroits les livres et pour les
petites entreprises parce que les
grandes magasins les grandes entreprises
étaient toujours dans une bonne position
mais c'étaient les petites entreprises
tant nos communautés locaux où on a vu
l'écran d'impact cette monnaie donc et
pas de nous on doit aller continuer mais
pas de moment où vous êtes vous encore
pour un autre trois mois ou six mois ou
namoya payet pas de date de péremption
la pauvre est pas si le moment parce que
avec la réalité sur le terrain le fait
que en alberta à ce moment en sociation
en ce moment en ce moment c'est vraiment
la pire situation avec une crise dans
les eaux pétales avec une crise avec les
gens qui tourne mal a donc à ce moment
c'est bien évident que on est dans une
quatrième bague qui frappe fort vous
avez dit déjà que vous étiez prête à
collaborer le gouvernement on vous
perçoit comme l'allié naturel des
libéraux elle est où la ligne où vous
décidez que vous n'appuyez pas le
gouvernement on est prêt de voter contre
le gouvernement n'importe quand on est
pro on est prêt de faire ça mais la
différence entre moi et les autres
partis d'opposition mon but ce n'est pas
de chercher et moment pour voter nous
mon but c'est de trouver des façons de
faire fonctionner ce gouvernement pour
les gens donc je n'ai pas une ligne
jaune ligne orange j'ai des valeurs et
les valeurs sont comment aider les gens
comment on peut investir dans nos soins
de santé il y à des mesures immédiates
qu'on veut voir une programme de congés
de maladie payés c'est quelque chose
qu'on a demandé on veut voir qu'il tombe
il arrête tout de suite de continuer les
poursuites contre les enfants
autochtones quelque chose que le cour de
justice a dit que vous devez arrêter et
maintenant dis clairement et dont ils
doivent prendre l'engagement d' arrêter
donc il ya plus et mes yeux comme ça la
ligne de cassure pour vous aider
si si vraiment si ça aide les gens nous
donc on est prêts dès beauté nous on est
prêts de voter contre le gouvernement
mais ce n'est pas mon but c'est pas mal
non vous n'êtes pas prêt à partir en
sélection mais matin et on peut la faire
n'importe quand mais pour nous pour moi
si si vraiment on est dans un point de
me rouler dans une crise on doit régler
cette crise assez pour moi priorité
alors combien de temps il convient tant
ce gouvernement la voix du jury des prix
m et si c'était ma décision je dis qu'on
va continuer de faire le travail pour
toute notre mandat parce que le goût
m'ont été choisi par les gens la série
votre décision c'est votre décision
quelque part nommé dans le passé c'était
le grand libéral qui est de décider de
déclencher une action donc vous vous
êtes prête à appuyer le gouvernement
pour la durée du mandat si ça vous
convient si ça convient les gens si ça
aide les gens 6 a livré la marchandise
pour les gens oui mais sinon on est près
de votre contre aussi monsieur scène y
aura un retour en chambre éventuellement
des parlementaires vous le voyez comment
se retournant je pense que le système
hybride à fonctionner donner une
opportunité pour les gens qui ont des
familles qui ont des défis pour aller à
toi de présenter de se présenter et de
participer donc je suis pur pour une
système hybride donc à 50 50 quel genre
de proposition vous envisagez on doit
suivre les conseils des experts en
matière de santé publique pour donner
une des stations physique entre les gens
donc je suis ouvert aux discussions qui
suivent les cons c'est d'avoir un retour
avec tout le monde dans la chambre c'est
parce que vous envisagez ou c'est parce
que vous préférez sinon à ces moments je
pense que ce n'est pas la bonne chose à
faire chaque meeting merci beaucoup